ROSS MCLACHLAN: All right.
So hi, everyone.
Let's start with a quick poll.
How many people here
are user researchers?
Hand up.
Got a couple.
How many people here
come from companies
who have user researchers?
OK.
There's a good few of you.
That's nice.
So I'm sure that you heard
earlier from some of the talks
today that improving
the quality of your app
is a really great way to boost
the star rating or your user
retention.
Many to the earlier talks
today kind of spoke to that.
You would have heard
Ricardo and Alexi talk about
how app quality was
really important,
and how you can use Android
Vitals to improve the quality
of your app after launch.
But what I want to
talk to you about today
is the process that informs
all of that, the process that
helps you ship a high-quality
app in the first place.
So rather than kind of
going with your gut,
and going to the market
hoping for the best,
this is about
using user research
to make sure that the
decisions you make
are as useful, objective,
and as sensible
as they possibly can be.
So how do you do that?
We all know that building
a product in a vacuum
is really not a great
way to create products
that users love.
So as user researchers
on the Google Play team,
it's our job to help the product
teams create experiences that
are useful, usable,
and desirable,
or even magical for our users.
So what I want to
talk to you today
is about how to make
the research you're
doing impactful.
And the real key to
doing impactful research
is not some silver
bullet method.
It's not some
fancy piece of kit.
It's not necessarily some
really complex process.
The real key to doing
impactful research
is making sure you get the most
out of the research you do,
and making sure that that
research gets used in some way.
So this talk is really just
about some insanely practical
methods and techniques
that will help you go away
and do better user research.
And your product is going
to be better because of it.
This is about whatever
you're doing right now,
and making sure that
that investment pays off.
If you get this right,
everything else gets easier.
So how do you do
impactful research?
What is that?
So I'm going to
share with you today
three mistakes that
we commonly see
people make when approaching
doing user research, and three
methods and techniques from
my experience as a researcher
on the Google Play team to
help you mitigate that risk
and to make the research
you do more impactful.
So the mistakes-- using the
wrong methods at the wrong
time, separating the research
from the rest of the team,
and asking the wrong questions--
have fairly
straightforward fixes.
But fixing them will
help you maximize
the value of the research you
do and make the most of the data
you collect in order to
make better decisions.
So-- mistake number one,
using the wrong methods
at the wrong time.
So research is really just
about asking good questions.
And depending on where you
are in the product life cycle,
you probably have different
questions that need answered.
That kind of makes sense, right?
So as your product
or feature evolves,
so do the kind of questions
that you need to ask.
But one mistake
we commonly see is
people trying to ask either the
same questions again and again
as their product
evolves, or trying
to answer different questions
with the same methods that
really don't fit.
So doing impactful
research is not just
about using impactful methods.
It's really about picking the
right methods for the questions
you have and asking the right
questions at the right time.
So on my team, when we think
about doing user research,
we start by thinking
whereabouts in the development
process we are.
And typically at a
high level, there's
only really three questions
that we need to answer.
The first one is, what to build?
The second one is,
how to build it?
And the third one
is, did we succeed?
And we call this strategic user
research, design user research,
and value to user research.
So each of these questions
has many, many, many different
method you can use, and
picking the right method
is going to help you maximize
how useful that answer is
to you.
There's probably too many
methods at each stage
than I can cover in this
talk, but let me walk you
through some of the stuff
that we do on Google Play,
highlighting the kind of
research we do at each stage.
So the first question we do,
or the first question we ask,
is what to build?
And this is kind of
strategic user research.
And really, the
goal here is to help
inform the product direction
and uncover new opportunities.
So what kind of research
can you do at this stage?
What methods can you do
to help you use this?
So one of our most
powerful tools for this,
on both the developer side
and on the consumer side,
are what we call immersion
or observational studies.
And this is really
just basically
watching people use
your product or feature,
understanding what they're
doing, and really asking them
why they're doing what
they're doing already.
The method is really
just watching your users
and asking them why.
At this stage in the
process, the goal
is to discover things you don't
already know and to deep dive
into topics that really
matter to your users.
Some of you may recognize
my colleague Phil here,
who is a researcher on
the Play Console team.
He does a lot of these kind
of studies with developers.
So what is the method here?
How do you make the most of
these observational studies?
It can really be as simple
as just sitting down
with a bunch of your users,
getting them to show you them
using your product or feature,
and just watching them do it,
asking them why
they're doing it.
But here's some
few techniques that
can help you make the most
out of those sessions.
The first one is not to
ask leading questions.
This is something we see
people do all the time.
And we invite sort of product
or eng into these sessions,
we see them asking
questions where
the answer that
they want to hear
is kind of embedded in the
question that they're asking.
So that's a really obvious one.
Don't do that.
The second one is
not really to ask
questions that can be answered
with a yes or no answer.
This is something else that
we really commonly see.
Do you want feature
A or B-- yes or no?
This is not great, as it really
doesn't get you very rich data.
You get one data point.
If you ask questions
that are more open-ended
and encourage your
users to talk,
you'll really get much
richer data out of them.
And the last thing
that we see people do
is drawing attention
to specific things
that they really care about.
This is bad as well, as it tends
to change users' behavior when
you're talking to them.
So don't draw
attention to things
like features or a
particular interface elements
that you want to know about.
You want to see if users
talk about them naturally
or see if they're
noticing them at all.
So observing your
users in this way
and understanding why they're
doing what they're doing
is a really great way to
uncover new opportunities
and guide the strategic
direction of your product.
So now you kind of have
an idea of what to build.
The next question we
ask is how you build it.
And this is the
stage where you're
trying to explore
design concepts
and trying to converge
somehow to an ideal solution.
So what research methods
can you use here?
So a method that we really like
that helps us support or design
solutions really quickly is
something that we call C-RITE.
C-RITE is a version of
traditional rapid iterative
testing and evaluative
methodology,
but it ensures
cross-disciplinary
collaboration on planning
and executing the research.
So C-RITE builds on a
traditional RITE methodology,
during which designs
are evaluated
in the agile,
user-centered framework.
And in RITE studies,
multiple stakeholders
collaborate in order to
iteratively build and test
prototypes.
But in these RITE studies,
stakeholders usually
have to commit to
maybe one or two
weeks of involvement,
which can be challenging.
But C-RITE addresses this by
reducing the collaboration
effort to about 2
and 1/2 days a week.
And in that time, design
problems are researched
and new ideas are designed
for and prototyped.
With C-RITE you can
go from research
to new design in one
day, and key stakeholders
collaborate in all UX spaces.
So what are the strengths here?
Why is this good?
The first one is that you
get the entire team engaged
in the process.
And I'm going to talk
about this some more later,
but that's a really
key thing to making
your research you do useful.
The second thing is it allows
really, really quick iteration.
So the research
insights that you get
are used almost
immediately, which
ensures that they're going to
be impactful down to the product
that you're building.
Stakeholders are highly
motivated with the opportunity
to express opinions
about what they've just
observed in the
research sessions, which
we find is a great kind
of motivator for people.
And as the product
[? owner, ?] being
able to listen to and engage
in discussions with all
stakeholders really creates some
really rich design discussions.
So the key here
with C-RITE is more
that the insights
are used immediately
and the whole team are
involved in the process.
And that's a really
key thing for making
this research you do impactful.
So that's an example of
how you can figure out
what to build and put
yourself in a good position
to know that you're
building the right thing.
So the next question we
ask is, did we succeed?
By this point in
the research, you're
probably in a great position.
You're confident that
your product is serving
some kind of need,
and you've kind of
ironed out all the usability
creases and [? have about ?]
all the usability issues
during C-RITE tests.
So here you don't necessarily
need to do anything complex.
You really just need
to pick whatever
it is you measure and
care about, and measure
it to see if it's gone up.
You're basically, well, in its
simplest form, you're basically
just asking, did we succeed?
You can do this with your
analytics or engagement data.
You can do this with
user satisfaction.
And you're basically
just trying to understand
if users are engaged
with and satisfied
with the product you built.
So we covered a bunch of
different research methods
that you can use at each
stage in this process.
And as I said before,
each method has,
or each question has
many different methods
that you can use, much
more than I have a chance
to cover in this talk.
But hopefully we
can kind of give you
a flavor of how you can
use different research
methods at each stage.
But the key here is that
picking the right methods
to use at the right
time will maximize
how useful the answer
is to you, and then
maximize the impact
that that research is
going to have on your product.
Using the wrong method
at the wrong time
can make the research
you do more difficult.
And the other key
thing with this
is the better job
you do answering each
of these questions successfully
reduces the amount of work
you have to do at each stage.
So if you do really
good strategic research,
you can go into
your design research
knowing that the
product you're building
is really serving a need.
You do really good
design research,
you can go to market knowing
that the usability and design
creases are all ironed out,
and then you really just
have to measure in
the evaluative stage.
So mistake number two,
separating research
from the rest of the team.
Among researchers, it's
common to hear research
being treated as
a separate unit,
or detached from the rest
of the product and eng
teams, and in that case, for
the product and eng teams
to become disconnected from
the research that's happening.
So in these kind
of situations, it's
kind of easy for the research
teams and product teams
to fall out of sync, and more
likely that the research that
gets done either isn't timely
or doesn't answer key questions.
So the thing that
we do here is really
to try and make
the methods we use
as collaborative as possible.
You want your team
members to feel ownership
over the results.
So good product
research isn't really
about an academic ivory tower.
You don't want research
to feel like it's
being handed down from
above with the product team.
And collaboration is a huge part
of avoiding that disconnect.
If you get people
involved in the research,
the research will
be more valuable,
and then it's more
likely to be used.
So this is an example
picture of the Play Console
team on a sort of research
trip, research immersion
trip a couple of years ago.
And here we have designer, eng,
eng, BD, product manager, BD,
eng, product manager and
researcher, all out together
on a trip going to visit
users, and to listen
to their problems, and try to
figure out product strategy,
and decide where to go.
So why is this good?
Involving the team is really
valuable for multiple reasons.
Not only did they get
a first-hand sense
of the insights, team members
get to meet face-to-face
with users.
There's lots of
cross-functional collaboration,
which is really good for a
really good enhanced sense
of team.
So this is a quote from
one of the engineers
who participated in the study.
So "these studies are great
and the feedback is invaluable.
I hope we can set up some
continuous direct communication
with developers in addition
to these regular studies."
We find that it's really
good for engineers
to be able to have first-hand
contact with their users
as well, as it really makes you
feel good knowing that you're
building something that's making
a difference to someone's life.
So we've covered when
to do research and some
of the techniques you
can use to increase
the value of your
research every stage.
So finally, I want to
share some techniques
that you can do to help
focus your research on topics
that you know are
going to be impactful.
So as I said before,
good research
is really about
asking good questions.
There's no point in asking the
same question again and again.
There's no point
in asking questions
that you don't necessarily
need the answer to.
And there's no point in asking
too many questions, that you
collect too much data, that
then you can't action all of it.
So in the Play Console team,
and on the Play team in general,
we have a whole
team of researchers
that can help with this.
We have experts in
trying to decide
what research needs to be
done and what doesn't, and how
to decide which questions
are most valuable.
And really, a key
thing if you want
to be able to do impactful
research, a really good thing
to do is to hire good
user researchers.
You're not going
to be able to learn
how to code or
learn how to product
manage from a 20-minute talk.
But if you don't have that,
and you don't have a dedicated
resource, and you're
trying to decide
where you should invest in
research, how can you do that?
So a good way to
do this is to be
looking at the reviews analysis
section on the Google Play
Console.
This is a great technique
to uncover topics
where you can improve your
app based on the star rating
or compared to your competitors.
The topic analysis
itself won't tell you
how to improve
something, but it will
let you guide the research
you do to areas where
you know you can have impact.
So you can look
for areas where you
need to understand more, i.e.
why are lots of my bad reviews
associated with
the topic profile?
You can find areas
where you want
to improve your star rating.
And you can find areas
where you can improve
compared to your competitors.
As I said, this is a great
way to direct research
to areas that can have
real impact to your app.
So how do you do that?
So in this section, you can
see how users of your app
compare to a bunch
of common topics
against most of the similar
apps in the same Play Store
category as you.
So these common
topics can include
things like design, profile,
resource usage, speed, et
cetera.
So I'm going to walk through a
few examples of how you might
do research if you find
that these topics are having
a negative effect on
your rating in some way.
So as I discussed earlier,
taking deep dives into things
that really matter
to your users is
one of the goals of
doing strategic research.
So it's a great
time to understand
why certain topics,
if you don't know why,
are pulling down your rating.
So you can use some
of the reasons listed
in the reviews against
something like resource usage
or uninstalls to understand
why your users are
unhappy with those things.
The chances are if people
have wrote reviews about it,
there'll be something
that users who
participate in your research
will have opinions on as well.
And the real key
here is to understand
what the expectations were,
and whether or not they
were met or unmet.
For design and usability,
this is a great time
to use something
like C-RITE again.
So you want to
explore design issues.
You want to explore usability
and explore new design
solutions.
And again, you
can use the topics
mentioned in the
individual reviews
to help guide the
actual research.
And then to deep dive
even further into topics
that are really
specific for your app,
you can look at those
really detailed topics
that come out of your reviews.
So you can use these as probes
in your research and reviews
to really understand
why users are talking
about, really,
things that are very
particular to your own app.
So what do I want you to
take away from this talk?
So doing impactful
research is not just
about some silver
bullet impactful method.
It's really about
picking the right method
to use at the right time
in your development process
to answer impactful questions
that are going to be
useful for your whole team.
And as I said
before, if you really
want to invest in good
impactful research,
then it's really great to go
and find good user researchers
to hire and join your team.
We're really nice people.
It's really good, honestly.
But if you can't do that, or
if you don't have enough user
research capacity
just now, I hope
that you'll find the simple
methods and techniques
in this talk useful
for going away
to do research that can help you
make your product or app much
better.
Thank you.